some would say that we're in a
post-feminist era because they hope it
will go away
[Music]
we are the revolution that is going to
see to it that no one is ever born into
an inferior role again because of race
or of sex the feminist is someone who
believes in the full humanity
of all people that's it
every single individual on the planet
deserves the same sovereignty over their
being and when you see that it changes
your world view on everything
there's a long history of people taking
their painful living truths and
channeling that into justice
so we've never had an attitude a
cultural response here in the united
states that said caregiving is actually
in the public interest
to watch this class you don't need to be
a woman you don't have to be an activist
feminism is open for everyone and it's a
way of challenging a division that
should not exist
justice is different for different
people in some states survivors are
charged for their rape kits it's such a
painful waste of time to fight so hard
to be ourselves the change comes from
the bottom up it's the whole nature of
even democracy itself whether you're
talking about abortion rights violence
against women or caregiving all lead you
to that place what is the world we
really want to have
i'm amanda nguyen i'm tina chen i'm
adrian marie brown i'm gloria steinem
and this is
[Music]
you